now this is great for JSON but what if
we want to grab something else say a
sound file to do that we need to set the
response type of the xml httprequest
object to array buffer and what that
will do is specify that it is binary
information rather than text that we can
then decode as necessary what we'd like
you to do is create another xml
httprequest but this time we're going to
request BG menu dog a sound file and set
the response type to array buffer now
we've already created the onload
function for you to use don't worry if
you don't understand any of this we'll
be going over this in more detail later
in the sound unit for right now your job
is just to fire off the xml httprequest